comme chaque jour des centaines de
mexicains traversent la frontière pour
venir travailler à el paso nous rendre
visite à leurs proches ou faire quelques
emplettes
depuis la fusillade de samedi dernier où
sept de leurs concitoyens ont été
abattus ces mexicains sont troublés par
cette flambée de violence dans une ville
beaucoup plus paisible que la leur
un agnelli nous confie qu'elle est plus
inquiète depuis la fusillade
de l'autre côté de cette clôture se
trouve leur lieu de naissance
ciudad juarez la ville soeur d'el paso
c'est l'endroit qu'est le titre peu
envié de capitale mondiale du meurtre à
cause de la bataille entre
narcotrafiquants explique daniel moreno
les morts s'empilent depuis les 15
dernières années l'insécurité y est
constante explique pétrin maroci surtout
pour les femmes qui ont été assassinés
par milliers même si les statistiques
sur la violence sont très différentes
entre el paso et ciudad juarez valeria
lopez estime que cette insécurité grandi
aux états unis depuis l'élection de
donald trump ou gauche américaine c'est
un homme dit elle qui répand le racisme
et le sentiment hostile envers les
latinos
pas étonnant que donald trump qui
visitera el paso mercredi après midi ne
soit pas le bienvenu dans cette ville
meurtrie à el paso majoritairement
latino qui avaient voté en très grand
nombre pour hillary clinton
le malaise est très présent rosie
mandour anneaux qui est venu apporter
des petits pendentifs symbole de
protection pour les disparus souhaite
que donald trump ne viennent pas ici
jack des loges parce qu il ne fait que
nous traiter de violeurs et de
revendeurs de drogue
il se fout pas mal de ce que nous sommes
dit elle santiago chavez qui est venue
avec ses deux filles se recueillir
devant la scène du crime et plus
diplômés ce n'est pas le bon moment pour
trame pis si la blessure est trop
profonde
ats dirige le parti républicain d'el
paso pour lui la visite présidentielle
est une très bonne chose
il n'est pas forcément d'accord avec
tout ce que donald trump dit mais ils le
respectent pour sa franchise
il a cependant un conseil pour le
président mais il ne faut pas qu ils
politisent sa visite il devra montrer de
la compassion et de la compassion les
gens d'ici en ont bien besoin alors que
les hommages continuent d'affluer pour
les morts de la fusillade
ici frédéric arnould radio canada el
paso